It's time for pop quiz!
Yes!
(audience cheer and clap)
Okay, where is audience member, Sedoni Francis?
Hello.
What a great name.
Right, Sedoni, do you wanna play?
(audience cheer and clap)
Hi!
How are you?
Hi, look at you.
Spring has sprung.
Yes, I had to get out that seasonal depression.
I know, it's true.
Color changes everything.
It really elevates the mood.
(audience cheer and clap)
Now, Sedoni, I hope you've been paying attention
all show long.
I hope I have too.
All right, we're gonna ask you some questions
about today's show and if you get all three right,
you're gonna win a $1,000!
$1,000!
(audience cheer and clap)
Good luck to you.
Thank you.
Okay, first question.
Netflix's upcoming biopic, "Blonde"
is about what famous actress?
And then later this year, Netflix is also releasing
their highly anticipated biopic "Blonde"
with Ana de Armas.
And she's playing Marilyn.
Marilyn Monroe.
That's right, that's right, one down.
You gotta get the next two right.
Here's question number two.
John Apatow was just on and he said he was once roommates
with one of Drew's frequent co-stars, who was?
You were roommates with Adam Sandler?
Yes, yes, I was.
Oh, I know this one, Adam Sandler.
That's right.
(audience cheer and clap)
Get in here, get in here.
Okay, as we get nervous, we get closer together.
No, I'm getting nervous too because I'm moving
and I really want the $1,000 to buy a new couch.
Oh, I want you to win so bad.
Okay, all you need to do
is answer this final question right.
Are you ready?
Okay.
Who did Bridget Moynahan play in "Sex and the City"?
I've loved you in so many different iterations,
and films, and movies, and characters,
but gosh, let's kick it off with Natasha.
I mean, "Sex and the City".
(audience cheer and clap)
You're so incredible as Natasha.
Oh my God, Natasha, Natasha.
(audience cheer and clap)
I'm so happy.
Now, that one was real.
I was struggling with that one.
You did it.
You nailed it.
I never watched "Sex and the City"
'cause I was too young when it aired,
so my mom didn't let me watch it.
Not a bad idea to not watch it as a kid,
but I will say you should sit down on your new couch
and binge it.
Yes!
(audience cheer and clap)
Thank you.
Also, I'm gonna match it
with a $1,000 gift card to let's say CB2.
Drew, girl.
That's happening.
My chest, oh my God, Drew.
So good luck in your new apartment.
Thank you so much.
Sit on that fabulous new CB2 couch.
I will, I love CB2.
Enjoy that cash, and definitely binge "Sex and the City".
I will, I'm gonna watch when I go home.
(upbeat music)